lynn is a software engineer at
salesforce
and an excellent teacher in this course
she will teach you how to solve
backtracking problems
which are common in coding interviews
and challenges
hi everyone i'm lin i'm a software
engineer hobbyist game developer
and recent graduate from the university
of chicago
welcome to this course on solving
backtracking problems
whether you are new to coding interviews
or already have experience with
backtracking problems
this is the crash course for you
we will learn about an all-purpose
template that helps you solve any kind
of backtracking problems
and we will apply the template to decode
problems like the 8
queens problem or the sudoku silver
problem
this is exactly the template that i use
for my code interview problems
when i'm developing algorithms for my
games or even ones in my research on a
non-convex optimization problem
i hope you're excited and let's dive
right into this versatile template
you can find this template in my github
just linked to in the video description
below
let's start with some keywords and
concepts in backtracking problems
that will help us understand the
template better the first keyword
state essentially a backtracking problem
is asking you to find valid states
take the n queens example that we will
solve later in this video
an example of a state is just
arbitrarily placing n queens on an
unbian board
for example here we are placing four
queens on a 4x4 board
on the contrary an example of a valid
state requires that
the queen are placed in a fashion not
they cannot attack each other
if you aren't familiar with the rules of
chess don't worry
the moves of queens are pretty
straightforward
a queen can move horizontally vertically
or diagonally therefore
for replacement of the n queens to be
valid they can't stand
on the same row the same column or the
two diagonals
so how do we construct a valid state
like this
well we build up from previous states
suppose we're starting from the blank
and by end board where no queen is
present we can put our first queen
arbitrarily wherever we want let's see
we put it here
then where can we place the second queen
you can see now our choices
are limited or in background terminology
our candidate
states are limited because we place the
first queen here
this entire column this entire row
and the two diagonals are now
unavailable for new queens
let's say we just put the second queen
here where it's available
next we try to see where we can fit in
the third queen
our candidates are now more limited
because we put the second queen here
this column this row and this diagonal
is not available
so our third queen can only go here
finally let's place the fourth queen
because this third queen is here it
blocks this diagonal
and this row and this column leaving our
fourth queen to set here
great now is this global layout a valid
solution such that no queen can attack
each other well we've already seen in
our checks
so like this we have found a valid
solution to this end queen problem
as a counter example consider if we
place the first two queens like this
now all these cells marked in red
are available and we only have one left
for the third queen
and nowhere to place the fourth queen
this means that this succession of state
searches fails to lead to a valid
solution
and this is pretty much it about states
identifying candidates to build the next
state
and validating a final solution now
let's look at how these procedures are
defined in our template
there are four functions in our template
the first
three is valid state get candidates
search or helper functions
the last and most important one so is
the entry point to our program
the so function is indeed the one that
the elite code problem is asking you to
write
it is responsible for returning the
valid solutions
let's look at the helper functions one
by one
this valid state this function takes in
a state
and returns a boolean it validates
whether a state can be used as a final
solution
in our quiz problem a state is a
validate solution
if all n queens are placed on the board
and none of them can attack each other
get candidates
this function finds a list of candidates
that can be used to construct the next
state
search this is a recursive function
it calls the previous two helper
functions and checks if the state is a
valid solution to our backtracking
problem
if it is it records the solution by
making a deep copy of the state
note that we do need a deep copy instead
of a shallow copy
because we will continue to modify the
state as our search goes
but we need a static snapshot of the
valid state here
this line of return is commented out
because depending on the nature of the
problem we might need to find
all valid solutions or just one if we
only need
one we can return as soon as we have
find it
otherwise we continue on until we
exhaust all the possible search states
continue down here if the state isn't
yet
a valid solution we find candidates to
build the next state
recall that candidates return a list of
candidates
for each one we add the candidate to the
state
in a quiz problem for instance suppose
our state only contains the position of
the first queen
here we add a candidate position for the
second queen
now we take this modified state and
recurse on it
by calling the search method on this
modified state
if the modified state is valid the
solution is recorded
like here otherwise the search function
fetches candidates for this modified
state and recurs further
eventually for some state there is no
more possible candidate
think that example where we cannot place
a fourth queen anywhere
because all the spaces have been
occupied
after returning from the recursive
search we restore the modified state to
the original
by removing the candidate from the state
again in the queen's example we undo the
placement of the
second queen and now we only have the
first queen
as for serve it starts with an empty
list of solutions
and an empty state a cost
search on the state and this list of
empty solution
search will eventually fill up this list
of empty solutions
and then return the list of solutions
and
remember this is the function that the
code problem is asking us to write
when using this template keep in mind
that this is only a template
so your helper functions is valid state
get candidates then by taking additional
parameters
search might also return a boolean
indicating whether a solution has been
found
and returned early if there is one and
only one valid global solution
like in the sudoku problem that we will
eventually see
this concludes our brief introduction to
the template
next let's solve the queen's problem
hands-on in lead code
here we are only code number 51 the end
queen's problem which is a legal heart
problem
let's first read the problem statement
given an integer n we want to return all
the distinct solution to the n queens
puzzle
and we may return the answer in any
order
and lico has a specific format for us to
represent the board
for four queens example these are the
two valid
solutions and here we denote that the
first
square on the first row is not occupied
the second square is occupied
by a queen the third one is not occupied
the fourth one is not occupied
and on the second row the first three
squares aren't
occupied and the last one is occupied by
queen so on and so forth
and in the case where n is 1 the queen
can only be under a single grid
so that's the solution before jumping
into the code let's first think about
how we may represent this problem
logically
we might be tempted to represent this
board data structure as a 2d
array but it's actually a little bit
waste of space to do so
since no queens can be on the same row
or the same column
we may just keep a 1d list that tracks
the queen's position
in each row
concretely for this example here on the
left
for the first row the queen is in the
second cell so the first
index is one
for the second row the index is three
since the queen
is in the fourth cell
and this here is zero
this here is two
following the same logic
for the example on the right the first
index is two
the second index is zero the third one
is
three and the last one one
because the third cell the first cell
the fourth cell and the second cell
so this is the way that will represent
each state
as a 1d list for this backtracking
problem
now i'm going to grab my template
and put it into the code
i'm going to move the soap method on top
as i already mentioned the silver method
is basically the one that the code is
asking us to write
so for the solve n queens problem we
will just be adapting the sole function
so solutions is initially an
empty list because we may return all the
valid solution
in any order then
my starting state is just
an empty list because
we haven't placed any of the queens into
the board just yet
then we call self.search
on the state giving it our list of
solutions to append to
and the parameter n for the n queens
after the search is complete we return
the solutions
let's go ahead and remove this part
great now we will write the is valid
state
function it will take as parameter solve
state and n for state to be valid
it needs to put all end queens onto the
board
so if the length of the state
is n then we know we have already put
all n queens onto the board as for the
condition where no queens can attack
each other
we will handle it in the get candidate
function
essentially we will only return
candidates that
land on valid squares that won't be
attracted by the previously placed
queens
so self state
and
great so here we are constructing
candidates based on the state that we
are given
if there is no state meaning that we are
starting from a blank board
we may place the first queen anywhere we
want
so if not state
we return all the possible indexes
if the state is not empty we find
the next position in the state to
populate
[Applause]
so position is the length of the state
if we already place the first queen we
want to place the second queen
so candidates initially start from
all the indices and then we prune down
candidates that aren't valid
i'm using a set because it's better than
walking through a list
and set guarantees uniqueness
all right let's prone down
candidates dot
place the queen into a text
so for row column in enumerate
state
we discard the we discard the column
index
if it's occupied
so candy dates got this card
recall that our state is recording the
column index
for each row now we discard the
diagonals
so distance is the distance between the
position
and the row index
because we're trying to put a queen in
the second row
now that we have already filled in the
first row we want it in a place that
cannot be attacked
by the first queen diagonally so
this one is out of the question and this
is
column plus distance this one is also
out of the question
column minus distance and at the very
end we return candidates
now let's define our recursive search
function
it should take some states solutions
and n we just adapt the template
so if self dot is valid state state
n
we just add it to the solutions and
return otherwise if we come down here
for candidates in self.candidates
state and
we recurse
because our state is a list and no
longer
is set we do append candidate
and then call self.search
state solutions and then
and then to restore the modified state
back to our original we pop the lost
entry
right so this here
is the only thing that we need to take
care of because leak wants us to output
strings and here we have is
a list of column indexes
so let's define some additional helper
functions here
state to string
so state n
[Applause]
and we expect the output to be
just like here
here's how we convert our list of
indexes
to this output string specified by the
code
so the return is just a list for
i in state
because one means that the queen is in
the second cell
and the other cells are empty we just
append the strings for the empty cells
as well the string for the
queen's concept notes together to get
the return value
string is this dot meaning
the empty square times i
plus the queen's position plus
the remaining empty cells
and red dot pan is great
and we return the red
and here is the solution at penn
state.copy
we do state stream
and state string is produced by
self dot state to string
state great
let's now run the example code to see
how we did
all right cool looks like our output is
accepted
let's submit and see whether we can pass
all the test cases
great you can see that our runtime
is better than almost 70 of the
submissions and also some memory usage
is better than seven percent of the
other submissions
we are definitely using some memory
because of the recursion
but that's totally okay for backtracking
problems
next we will solve another leaked heart
problem called the pseudocode silver
problem
we are now only called problem 37 the
sudoku solver problem which is a hard
problem
if you don't already know what a sudoku
puzzle is you can read the description
so a sudoku solution must satisfy all
the following rules
each of the digits 1 to 9 must occur
exactly once in each row
and in each column also in
nine of the three by three sub boxes of
the grid
and liquid used the dot character to
indicate empty cells
so for example here liko want us to
write a program that fills
out this sudoku puzzle
in a valid way the board
is represented as a 2d array
of strings some maybe numbers some are
empty cells
and liko wants us to solve the problem
and modify the board
in place
the constraints are that because it's a
sudoku problem
the shape is 9x9 and each
cell is either a digit string or the
empty string
and it's guaranteed that the input board
has only one solution so we may return
early
before you find only one solution
let me copy paste my template and jump
into the problem
all right so again we adopt the soap
function
like this because it asks us not to
return anything and just modify the
board in
i think we'll just need to do
self.search
board
and then we can get rid of this so
function
i'm going to have to define
some constants here so the shape
is 9x9 the grid
length is 3x3 if we are trying to
validate the sub boxes
and empty is represented as this dot
here
and all the digit strings are
like follows so screen
number four number in range
[Applause]
one shape plus one so this gives
us the strain from one to nine and i'm
going to wrap it in a set
because the order is not important
and i know i'm going to need this when
i'm traversing the grid
great so let's start by writing the is
valid
state function
so it should take self and the board
and check if the board is a valid
solution
so let's validate
all the rows first
for row and i'm going to just
define some helper function later down
so let's do
first soft get rows which returns
each row of the board one by one
if if my row is equivalent to all the
digits
then it's a valid row otherwise it's
an invalid row and the entire board is
not valid
if not set row is equal to self.digits
return false validate
similarly we validate the columns
because
return false and lastly we validate
the sub boxes
foregrip and self thought to get great
board
and if all the rows
are validated all the columns are
validated and all the grids are
validated without
causing this false return early we
return true
meaning that the board is now a valid
solution
now let's write get candidates
so self board
a row and a column
i'm using the row and the column because
for eight
cell i want to know which row and which
column it is on
to determine what digits have already
been used
and what are left for us to use as a
next state
so used digits
is a set of digit and
i'm going to
remove used remove digits
used by the same row
so used digits
dot update self dot
get okay
bro this is another helper function that
i will define
later down
move digits used by the
same column so use
digits dot update
self dot get paid column
four and a column
and remove digits used
by the same by the
by the three by three sub box
so use digits
dot update get
grid at row
and column so we need to identify for an
arbitrary cell
which grid it is on
board row call and
lastly because we might have already
used the
empty string here when we are doing the
updates
we subtract those from our use digits
self dot empty is the constant that we
defined for the empty string
and candidates are just
whatever that's left for us to use
so the all used ones
[Applause]
and that concludes our get candidate
function
now we are moving on to do search
because we only have one single solution
we don't need
the list of solutions here so self
and board
we have this valid state so if self dot
is valid state
board we return
true found solution
otherwise we find the next
empty spot and take a guess
so for row index
row in enumerate
board
for column index the
actual element in enumerate row
if the element is the empty string
so soft dot empty
for if this is empty
find candidates to construct the next
string
next stage
candidate a self dot get candidates
for now that we have the row index and
column index we pass those
in
we modify the board in place as the
problem instructed us to do so
candidate remember that candidate is
just one of the digit string
and because here our search returns a
boolean if one of the search
actually finishes that means that the
board has been modified in place
and our problem is solved so it's solved
is now
equal to self.search
board and
just to add some comment here
we recurse on the modified
board
if it's soaked
if it's soaked then we just return true
meaning that the entire search has
completed
otherwise we undo
the wrong guess and start a new
so we make this
entry back into the empty string that it
was
and down here we have exhausted all the
candidates
but none solves the problem
we return false because
this is an invalid succession of
searches
and if no empty
spot in the first place
then we just return true and we can get
rid of this
boilerplate code from our template
now the structure is pretty much clear
and all i need to do is to
fill in those hopper functions
helper functions for retrieving
rows columns and grids
so here are my helper functions for
retrieving rows columns and grids
this is pretty straightforward because
our board is just
a 2d array and to retrieve the kth row
case column or grid other certain row
and column
indexes we are basically just doing some
really smart
indexes and sometimes relying on
the power of either tools
i will post my complete code all my
github linked
in the description so you can digest
those helper functions on your own
now let's run the code and see what we
get
great our output is accepted let's
submit and
test it against all the test cases
awesome with this template we solve two
legal heart problems
to recap a back checking problem is all
about finding valid states
to solve for a valid state we identify
candidates that satisfy the problem
constraint
and use them to build upon our current
state
once a modified state is valid we add it
as a final solution
now that we have solved two problems
hands-on let's take another look
at our template
recall that we have these four functions
its valid state is a helper function
with a boolean return value
that validates whether a given state is
a funnel solution
get candidates is another helper
function returning a list of candidates
satisfying the problem constraint based
on our current state
search is a recursive function across
the two hopper functions
is valid state and get candidates
and recurs on itself
lastly solve is the function that a
legal problem
is asking you to write it does nothing
fancy other than
initializing an empty list of solutions
an empty state
and calling search on them
for more practice problems on
backtracking
go to leakcode.com and in text search
for
backtracking this filters out
a list of questions that all shares the
backtracking idea
you see we already solved sudoku solver
and
n queens if you're looking for a medium
hard problem
i recommend the subsets problem
this is about finding all possible
subsets
or power sets of a given integer array
it is pretty easy to identify a
backtracking problem
when we are asked to find all possible
solutions
and may return the solution in any order
as you can see in my submission details
i solved the subsets problem using the
exact template
as you go through more and more lead
code problems and test how much you
understand about the template
you will be better prepared to identify
a backtracking problem once you
encounter one in your coding interviews
this concludes our video and the only
crash course you ever need for solving
backtracking problems on your code
interviews
for more content like this please
subscribe to my youtube channel
linksdevelop i also post fun project
tutorials and my game development demos
on my channel
my latest tutorial is about building a
discord ai chatbot with the personality
of your favorite character
using entirely cloud-based technologies
and i'm sure you will enjoy it
thanks for watching and best of luck
prepare for code interviews